[موسيقى]
رمضان مبارك وتقبل الله طاعتكم في شهر
الصيام نستحضر بعضا ولو يسيرا من معاناه
من يبيتون على الجوع وهم مع الاسف عشرات
الملايين في وطننا العربي فوفق تقرير اممي
فان الجوع في العالم العربي ارتفع بنسبه
90% في غضون 20 عاما كما ان هناك 141
مليونا يعانون من انعدام الغذاء المعتدل
او الشديد يمثلون تقريبا ثلث سكان المنطقه
هذا وفق تقديرات تعود الى عام 2020
والارقام للاسف في تزايد فكيف سيكون حال
هؤلاء في شهر الصوم والعطاء خاصه في الدول
العربيه غير النفطيه ومعظمها يعاني من
ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وارتفاع اسعار
المواد الغذائيه بفعل تداعيات جائحه
كورونا والصراع الدائري في اوكرانيا
دولنا العربيه تستورد اكثر من 50% من
احتياجاتها من المواد الغذائيه ويعتمد
العديد منها على واردات الحبوب والزيوت من
روسيا واوكرانيا فاتوره الاستيراد باهظه
وتقدر بعشرات المليارات من الدولارات ترهق
كاهل الدول العربيه يحدث هذا رغم ان مساحه
الاراضي العربيه الصالحه للزراعه تقدر
بنحو 220 مليون هكتار لا يستغل الا ثلثها
في قصتنا الليله الامن الغذائي العربي
نرصد بالارقام واقع الانتاج الزراعي في
عالمنا العربي وما يواجهه من تحديات سواء
في الاهتمام الحكومي وفي توفير التمويل
والاستثمارات وتطوير اليات الانتاج نستقصي
اراء فلاحين من تونس وسودان ولبنان
يتشبثون بالارض لكنهم لا يجدون من يشد
ازرهم ويخفف المعاناه عنهم ليستمروا
وارضهم في العطاء نستكمل بقيه قصتنا مع
فاضل الزعبي الخبير في الامن الغذائي
بمركز جناف للدراسات والممثله السابق
لمنظمه الفاو في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
والدكتور مازن سويد رئيس مؤسسه
الاستثمارات في لبنان خبير الاقتصاد
الدولي نسال ضيفين عن مفهوم الامن الغذائي
وكيف يمكن ان يتحقق في دولنا وعن سبل
معالجه التحديات التي تواجه الانتاج
الزراعيه والغذائي وتحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي
في العالم العربي وعن فاعليه مشاريع
التكامل بين الدول العربيه لتحقيق الامن
الغذائي المشترك والقضيه تفرض نفسها او
تفرض نفسها عفوا على اشغال جامعه الدول
العربيه منذ سنوات بعيده كما نسال ضيفين
عن التداعية الاجتماعيه والسياسيه
لاستمرار الفجوه الغذائيه في العالم
العربي لكن لنشاهد القصه بدءا وبعدها
الحوار
[موسيقى]
امن الغذائي ما يجيش
وبالمزايدات السياسيه يجيب العمل بالانتاج
وهذا ماهوش متوفر احد الاسباب وراء ذلك هو
بعض السياسات التي نتبعها في العديد من
الدول نحن من الدول التي ارهقت استيراد
القمح فيها الخزين العامه للدوله السياسات
المتبعه في الدوله السودانيه فيما يخص
النشاط الزراعي سياسات هامه وبالتالي
مدمره لموضوع الامن الغذائي الكل مستشعر
خطوره عدم توفر الامن الغذائي في المنطقه
العربيه
ما عندناش خط الزراعيه الدوله ما بتدعم
الخطوط الزراعيه هل سنبقى اليوم كعرب
نعتمد على زراعات الدول الاخرى حتى يبقى
امن الغذاء غير مهدد
يجابه الوطن العربي تحديا كبيرا يتمثل في
تامين الغذاء للشعوب في ظل نقص سلاسل
امدادات الغذاء عالميا اذ يستورد نحو 60%
من احتياجاته للحبوب عبر موسكو
ويستحوذ على نحو خمسه وعشرين بالمئه من
انتاج الحبوب العالمي فيما لا ينتج سوى
اثنين ونصف بالمئه وتستورد الدول العربيه
55% من احتياجاتها الاساسيه من المواد
الغذائيه بفاتوره بلغت قيمتها نحو 61
مليار دولار عام 2020
ولكن نقطه المثيره للاهتمام انه اذا
انتقلنا جميعا الى ما نسميه نظام غذائي
الصحي فان ذلك لن يحل المشكله حق لذا اذا
اردنا تغيير نظام غذائي فان ذلك لا يعني
انه ستكون هناك واردات اقل من الحبوب
بلا سيمبورتو نحن من الدول التي ارهق
استيراد القمح فيها الخزينه العامه للدوله
عندنا يعني انتاج محلي ممكن نقدره من
القمح ب 15% من جمله الاستهلاك
في السودان
85% ديال النسبه المتبقيه هي النسبه
المستورده بنستورد من الخارج بنغطي بها
الفجوات
اذا انت تستورد 60% من محصول معين من خارج
المنطقه العربيه ويعتبر ان يعني ظهرك
مكشوف لانه ممكن تحصل نوائب في مناطق اخرى
مناطق الانتاج التقليديه تحدث فيها بعض
الاشكالات كما حادثه الان واحنا شايفين
يعني
[موسيقى]
تفاجا الجميع ان العرب ومعظم دول العالم
ومنهم لبنان يعتمد بشكل اساسي ومركزي على
منتجات
الاوكرانيه الروسيه اتحدث عن القمح بشكل
اساسي وعن الزيوت بكل متفرعاتها لكن
السؤال اليوم للغد هل سنبقى اليوم كعرب
نعتمد على زراعات الدول الاخرى حتى يبقى
امن الغذاء غير مهدد تبلغ المساحه المقدره
للزراعه في العالم العربي نحو 220 مليون
هكتار يستغل منها 30 ونصف بالمئه فقط وهي
التي تعادل المساحه الكليه لدول تصنف
معظمها ضمن اكبر خمسه عشره دوله مصدره
للقمح في العالم مثل اوكرانيا ورومانيا
الا ان متوسط الانتاج الزراعي العربي يمثل
نحو اربعه بالمئه من الانتاج العالمي فقط
لانه المساحات المزروعه من مجموعات الغذاء
الاساسيه لا تتعدى 42 مليون هكتار هناك
هذه الكم الهائل من الاراضي والمساحات غير
المستقله هي حقيقه مستقبل قضيه الامن
الغذائي في العالم العربي
بطريقه هيكله نظام الزراعه والصعوبات التي
قد يضطر المزارعون الى الاستثمار فيها في
التكنولوجيا وانظمه التعليم المناسبه
لزياده المحصول
تقدر المساحه الصالحه للزراعه في السودان
بنحو 84 مليون هكتار يتم استغلال 20% منها
فقط كما ويمتلك ثروه مائيه لا تتوفر في اي
بلد عربي سواه اذ يحتوي على عشره انهار
تتنوع بين التدفق الموسمي والدائم
بالاضافه لمعدل امطار سنوي يزيد على 400
مليار متر مكعب تلك الموارد التي وضعت
السودان في مرتبه سله الغذاء العربي لكنه
على الرغم من ذلك فهناك اكثر من 9.8 مليون
سوداني يعانون من الجوع الحاد وفقا
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي التابع للامم
المتحده
[موسيقى]
المساحات موجوده الخبره موجوده البنى
التحتيه على قله ايضا موجوده فدوله زي
السودان الاشكاليه الاساسيه فيها يعني
قضيه استخدام التقانه الاستعداد والدخول
للموسم الزراعي والبنى التحتيه المطلوبه
والتشريعات والسياسات المطلوبه كلها فيها
اشكالات ومحتاجه لضبط العمل الزراعي عمل
متكامل فاذا اذا كانت لدي خارطه زراعيه
فانا احتاج
للمياه احتاج لعماله اذا ما كان عندي
ميكنه زراعيه كامله
بالتالي الامكانات هي اول اول اول ما يقف
في في وجه استغلال هذه المساحه بالصوره
بالصوره
اسست الدوله السودانيه اربعه مشروعات
تنمويه بغرض المساهمه في تحقيق الامن
الغذائي كان من ضمنهم مشروع السوكي
الزراعي الذي يشغل حاليا نحو 52,000 هكتار
ويمتلك ثروه حيوانيه تتجاوز ثلاثه ملايين
راسا يستفيد منهم 700 الف مواطن في 160
قريه
[موسيقى]
متوسطه الداخلي بتاع العمله الصعبه من
المشروع في ظروف المتوسطه او الطبيعيه
في حدود 250 مليون دولار القطن 100
الذره الرفيعه ثم باقي المحاصيل في الفتره
الاخيره اكثر من 15 سنه الكلام ده ما قاعد
يحصل وكان في انهيار كثير جزء كبير من
الشباب يتشردوا جزء من الناس نزحوا المبلغ
المطالب له المزارعين من الشركه الافريقيه
الوسطى او احد الشركات التعاقديه حوالي
620 مليون جنيه كما ورد في مستندات الشركه
بعضهم تم سجنه
والاباقين متعارضين وهذا طبعا يترك اسر
سلبي جدا جدا على الايمان بالزراعه نفسها
تاسس المشروع على 4 طرمبات لكن لاحقا سنه
2010 بعد اربعين سنه تم استبدال هذه
الطرمبات بالترمبات اخرى من نفس الشركه
وزاره الماليه دفعت مبلغ 157 الف طلبت
كمبلغ صيانه 2017 دفعت 2022 هذه الاسباب
كلها ادى لدمار مشروع السوكي
[موسيقى]
حسب منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه التابعه للامم
المتحده فان القطاع الزراعي في لبنان
يتمتع بامكانات جيده واراضي زراعيه متنوعه
لكنه على رغم ذلك يعاني العديد من العوائق
ايضا ابرزها العماله غير النظاميه وتنظيم
ملكيه الاراضي وصعوبه حصول المزارعين على
الدعم والتمويل وفقا لمعهد كارنيجي للشرق
الاوسط
خطه زراعيه الدوله ما بتدعم ولا عنا خطه
زراعيه يعني المبيدات والاسمده غالي
واليد العامله غالي واسعار
الاثمار اللي عم نبيعها احنا قليله وما
ليش تصريف كانت تساعد وتدعم القطاع
الزراعي في لبنان وان كان هذا القطاع كان
يريد ويحتاج دعما اكبر بذلك لكن بطبيعه
الحال نتيجه الظروف الاخيره بات الدعم غير
ممكنه لا بل مستحيل لذلك نعتمد اليوم على
الدعم الذي ياتينا بالهيئات المانحه
والمؤسسات الدوليه وزاره الزراعه قديش
موازنتها لا تتعدى او تحت الواحد بالميه
من الموازنه العامه فهذا بتثبت انه رؤيه
الحكومه في انه هذا القطاع مكلف غير منافس
وخلق نوع من عجز في هذه القطاع وعدم
اهتمام فيه
[موسيقى]
ثمه مبادره تعتبر الاولى من نوعها بسهل
البقاع في لبنان تاسست عبر الجمعيه
اللبنانيه للدراسات والتدريب عام 2019 تحت
مسمى القريه الزراعيه والتي امنت الكثير
من فرص العمل لشرائح واسعه بالمنطقه يحاكي
المشروع التوجه الانمائي للزراعه بشراكه
مع اليونسيف ويتضمن الارشاد والتدريب
الزراعي ونماذج زراعيه للكثير من الخضار
والفاكهه وتسويق الانتاج
بخطتنا اللي اعتمدناها حاولنا ان نوسع
شبكات المياه من خلال بناء اكثر من 70 الى
80 الف متر من الاقم الزراعيه سهوله وصول
المياه
المجانا الى الاراضي الزراعيه عزز استثمار
الارض على مدار السنه لانه نحن وقت اللي
وفرنا الشتور وفرنا المياه وفرنا الاسمده
خففنا كثير من الكلفه الزراعيه عند
المزيره فاعتبر وكانه هو يستثمر بالمجان
هناك عندك مناقل عن 2500 مزارع اليوم في
البقاع بيستفيدوا من الارشادات والمدارس
الزراعيه بنقدم من منتوجات القرن الزراعيه
حصص غذائيه مصنعه محليا لالفين عائله طبعا
هيدي كانت بشراكه مع منظمه تونس وشركائه
ممكن نوصل الى اكثر من 3000 عائله
يستفيدوا من انتاج الحبوب
تعتبر الزراعه التونسيه احدى ركائز
الاقتصاد الوطني اذ تساهم بنحو
11.2% من الناتج الداخلي بالاضافه ل 13%
من الصادرات فيما تستقطب نحو سبعه بالمئه
من جمله الاستثمارات في الاقتصاد الوطني
وتوفر ما نسبته 18% من فرص العمل تبرهن
تلك الارقام على اهميه قطاع الزراعه في
تونس لكنه على الرغم من ذلك فان الدعم
الذي تقدمه الحكومه لزراعه متواضع
بالمقارنه مع قطاعات اخرى كالسياحه
والصناعه
[موسيقى]
تقول لي شنو هي الحاجات اللي الباهيه
الفلاح التونسي ما نلقاش لك حتى ايجاب
غياب موارد تمويل لانه اليوم مؤسسه
الماليه في تونس ما تنجمش تعطيك قروض 80%
من نسبه القروض اللي في السنوات الاخيره
توجهت القطاعات اخرى اللي هي القطاعات
السياحه والصناعه الامن الغذائي ما يجيش
بالمزايدات السياسيه يجيب العمل بالانتاج
وهذا ما هوش متوفر
من العوامل المهمه ايضا هيكل نظام الزراعه
80% من المزارع هي عباره عن مزارع صغيره
جدا تستخدم 20% من الارض ومن ناحيه اخرى
10% من المزرعه تستخدم 60% من الاراضي
الصالحه للزراعه
تنذر التغيرات المناخيه في العالم بان
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا تتعرض
لتغيرات كبرى في معدلات هطول الامطار ادت
بشكل واضح الى ندره الموارد المائيه
المتاحه مما يترك اثرا على القطاع الزراعي
وانتاج الغذاء وفقا لمنظمه الاغذيه
والزراعه التابعه للامم المتحده
كميه الامطار صارت قليله وبقى يجي ساقعه
وجليد قبل اكثر اجليد هذا هاي الاشجار
المعمره بيجي القشر بيخلق تحت منه
هذا بيقتله اجت ساعه اثرت كثير على كل شيء
على الاشجار واثرت على المزروعات الصيفيه
في العوامل المناخيه هذه والجفاف ونقص
ندره المياه خلت الفلاحين يقلوا من مساحات
وهذا معناها السياسه بشد فيها حتى الدوله
وما هياش مخفيه تخرج معناها مناشير وتحذر
الفلاحين انهم باش يحدوا من نسبه الزراعه
لما نقارن نفسنا مع العالم ونقول انه في
جزء اكل كبير من الوطن العربي معدلات هطول
الامطار تتراوح بين 200 الى 400
مليمتر في العام هذه كافيه لانتاج جل
المحصولات اللي عندنا فيها ميزات نسبيه
على الصعيد الاخر استخدامنا لها ليس مرشد
هناك هدري للموارد المائيه في نهايه الامر
يتشكل في شح حقيقي للموارد المائيه في
المنطقه العربيه
بحسب تقرير المنظمه العربيه للتنميه
الزراعيه لعام 2020 فان تحقيق الامن
الغذائي بصوره مستدامه في العالم العربي
يواجه العديد من المشاكل المزمنه ابرزها
توسيع القدرات الانتاجيه ونظم الري
القديمه بالاضافه الى احتياج كبير لدعم
وتشجيع الزراعه والتصنيع الغذائي ما يثير
الكثير من التساؤلات حول سبل معالجه ازمه
الغذاء العربيه وارساء نظم غذائيه زراعيه
دائمه تدفع الدول العربيه الى التوازن بين
الانتاج والاستهلاك
اعتقد ان العديد من الحكومات تدرك بانه
ليس من الممكن ان تكون مكتفيا ذاتيا من
الغذاء لذلك يجب ان تكون هناك سياسات تضع
فيها التوازن والاكتفاء الذاتي من حيث
انتاج الغذاء والواردات والتنميه
الاقتصاديه للبلد ككل
تم اجراء الخارجي العرب في الكويت
وتحدثوا عن احياء مبادره الامن القسائي
العربي عدينا حاجه سميناها البرنامج
المستدام للامن الغذائي العربي بنينا فيه
على الاستراتيجيه دي قال له فيها يعني
الضبط واحكام النظم الزراعيه والغذائيه في
العالم العربي هناك اشياء كثيره ممكن
نتحدث فيها
وفاقد محتاج لمعالجات زياده في الانتاج
والانتاجيه هذه كلها محتاجه لمقاربات فنحن
قمنا بناء على هذا الطلب قلنا عندنا ما
يعرف بالبرنامج المستدام للامن الغذائي
العربي القطاع الزراعي في لبنان اليوم
نريد ان يكون هو ام القطاع وزاره الزراعه
نريدها ان تكون سياديه بامتياز هذا قولا
وعملا وفعلا لا يمكن لاي دوله ان تقف على
قدميها وقطاع الزراعي المتاهل نحن يحدون
الامل وسنعمل على هذا الامر ان يكون
القطاع الزراعي قطاعا منتجا واعيدا باذن
الله تعالى من خلال المشاريع الاملائيه
الزراعيه المستدامه التي تاتي بالشراكه مع
الامم المتحده مع هيئات المانحه وهذا طبعا
سيكون عمل مستدام ومستمر
[موسيقى]
امنا في ان الاجيال القادمه تاخذ المشعل
والدافع على حقها وتخدم ارضها تجتهد هذا
هو امل طموحاتنا يعني
ما انا محدوده بصراحه لانه هذا مساله حياه
مساله وجود يعني ما عنا انتباه للمخاطر
اللي ممكن نتعرض لها لذلك بنطبخ يكون هناك
فرصه جديده للشباب العربي بانه ان لا يرحل
لا يغادر ان يبقى في ارضه وفي بلده يطوره
ويصنع ويحقق امن الغذائي وامن الاقتصاد
انا بحب الارض وبعشق الارض وربيت بالارض
والى فضله على الارض اذا بخسر بدي ظل ازرع
وظلوم وانكشهم
خلال العشرين عاما الماضيه ارتفعت نسبه
الجوع في دول شرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
باكثر من 90% اذ عانى ما يقرب من ثلث سكان
المنطقه اي مئه و 141 مليون شخص من انعدام
الامن الغذائي المعتدل او الشديد في عام
2020 بزياده قدرها 10 ملايين عن العام
الذي سبقه وهو ما ينذر وفقا لشركه فيروس
الاستشاريه للمخاطر باحتمال نشوب اضطرابات
اجتماعيه جراء الازمه الغذائيه في عدد من
الدول العربيه
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيفينا
الكريمين معنا من عمان الدكتور فاضل
الزعبي الخبير في الامن الغذائي بمركزي
جناب للدراسات والممثله السابق لمنظمه
الفاو في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ومن بيروت
الدكتور مازن السويد وهو رئيس مؤسسه
الاستثمارات في لبنان وخبير الاقتصاد
الدولي اهلا بضيفينا الكريمين كل عام
وانتم والمشاهد الكريم بالف خير رمضان
مبارك على الجميع وعلى امه محمد نبدا معك
دكتور فاضل
وتبعنا هذا الفيلم الذي رصد واقع الدول
العربيه فيما يخص امنها الغذائي الذي
يعتبره كثر موضوعا سياديا في الواقع كيف
يمكن ان تقيم بنظره فاحصه الامن الغذائي
في المنطقه خاصه الدول العربيه غير
النفطيه التي تعاني من العديد من المشاكل
الاقتصاديه التي تنعكس بشكل مباشر ونتساءل
حقيقه
كيف تؤثر على جيب المواطن البسيط على سله
غذائه وعلى مائده افطاره في هذا الشهر
الفضيل
شكرا الك هذا موضوع مهم جدا وحتى استطيع
ان ابدا به خليني اذكر كل اصحاب القرار في
الشان الزراعي بان موضوع الامن الغذائي
كان في ادنى
اهتماماتهم خلال السنوات الماضيه
وكان هذا الموضوع لا يلقى الاهتمام الكافي
سواء من مؤسسات الدوله او حتى القطاع
الخاص
ولذلك ارتفعت نسبه الجواهر ارتفع نسبه
الجوهره في وطننا الى 90% الان مع كورونا
والازمه الاوكرانيه اصبح هنالك اهتمام
وهذا نلاحظه الاهتمام على صعيد معظم
الحكومات واصحاب الشان الزراعي وحتى
الاعلام العربي هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى وهي نقطه مهمه جدا انا بدي ابسط
الموضوع بالنسبه لدولنا
واقسمها الى ثلاثه اقسام عنا الدول
النفطيه اللي لديها القدره الماديه على
استيراد وتسديد فاتورتها الغذائيه بالرغم
من ارتفاع اسعارها وعنا الفئه التي تعاني
هي الدول التي تمر بنزاع وصراع وهذا نراه
جليا في اليمن والصومال وسوريا وغيرها
ولدينا الدول التي
تعاني من اقتصادها ولديها نسبه تضخم عاليه
وهذا يجعلها ايضا في الزاويه الحرجه
بالنسبه للامن الغذائي ما تم التركيز عليه
في هذا التقرير الرائع واللي بين الكثير
من الزوايا تم التركيز على نقطه واحده في
الامن الغذائي وركن واحد في الامن الغذائي
هو الوفره توفر الماده الغذائيه الانتاج
الزراعي لكن ما نحن يجب ان ننظر اليه وهو
حقيقه يعاني منه هو القدره على الوصول
القدره على الشراء وهذه نتيجه الفقر
وازدياد نسبه الفقر وازدياد من هم تركوا
اعمالهم بسبب كورونا
وانخفاض الدخل حتى بسبب كورونا لغايه الان
هذا طبعا اضافه الى الوضع الاقتصادي
والتغير المناخي والازمات الاقتصاديه
العالميه وبما اني ذكرت هذه النقاط مجتمعه
دعيني اذكر بان ما يتم حاليا بالرغم من
الاهتمام
المناسب او غير مناسب او المهم الاهتمام
لاكثر من اول من قبل المسؤولين عن الزراعه
ما يتم حاليا هي مجموعه مشاريع مبعثره
وجهود مبعثره وتناول الموضوع بشكل لا يمكن
ان يؤدي الى استدلال لموضوع مثل هذا وهو
يعتبر الامن الغذائي للدول موضوع سيادي
لانه قد يتسبب في مشاكل وقلاقل اجتماعيه
هذه الدول هي في غنى عنها دعني اتحول
للدكتور مازن يعني مثل ما ذكرنا رمضان
ياتي هذا العام ومعظم الدول غير النفطيه
تحديدا يعني تعاني من تضخم كما ذكر
الدكتور فاضل من مشاكل اقتصاديه عديده
ونتساءل حقيقه كيف سيؤثر كل ذلك على اسعار
المواد الغذائيه كيف رصدتم ذلك وعلى
القدره الشرائيه للمواطن البسيط واعداد
الجوعه للاسف الشديد في العشرين سنه
الماضيه كما ذكرنا يعني قفز الى قرابه
التسعين بالمئه
يعني اولا شكرا على الاستضافه ورمضان كريم
لك سيدتي على امل ان يكون
مصدر خير للجميع وازدهار على عالمنا
العربي كما تقولين اليوم تتوفى يعني هيك
تتلبد الغيوم ليس فقط حول عالمنا العربي
ولكن فوق العالم بما يسمى
او العاصفه الكامله مع انهيار المصارف في
امريكا الذي ياتي على اثر تضخم هائل في
العالم وعلى اثر حرب وخروج من جائحه
كورونا طبعا كل هذه العوامل تؤدي الى ما
يسمى اضطرابات في سلسله العرض او يعني
ما تؤدي الى ارتفاع مطرد في اسعار كل
المواد وبالاخص المواد الغذائيه وهذا تحدي
اساسي لعالمنا العربي الذي لم يكن جاهزا
لمواجهه هكذا تحديات كما قال زميلي الفاضل
لاننا لم نسعى يوما للنظر الى هذا الموضوع
موضوع الامن الغذائي كموضوع سيادي وانا
اريد ان اذهب ابعد من ذلك هو ليس فقط
موضوع سيادي هو موضوع لا يعالج الا من
خلال ما يسمى او المقاربه الاقتصاد الكلي
لانني اريد ان اتابع موضوع ذكره الزميل
انه عندما نتكلم عن الامن الغذائي هناك
اربعه اركان وليس ركن واحد هناك ركن الذي
يتعلق بتوفر الغذاء اذى هناك ركن الذي
يتعلق بالقدره للوصول على الغذاء اكسسبلتي
هناك ركن الذي يتعلق بصحه استعمال الغذاء
او فود سيفتي وهنا ركن رابع الذي يتعلق
باستقرار العرض والاسعار وهو السبيلتي اي
مقاربه لموضوع الامن الغذائي يجب ان تقارب
هذه الاركان الاربعه وبالتالي هي لا يمكن
ان تكون الا مقاربه مكروه اقتصاديه كامله
تتعلق بتطوير البنى التحتيه طرق شبكه نقل
كهرباء
خطه خطه صحيه خطط حمايه اجتماعيه خطط
اقتصاديه ماليه تتعلق بعلى ماذا
نحصي الضرائب وعلى ماذا نوفر الدعم نقديه
تسعى الى التالم مع التكافل مع السياسات
النقديه العالميه لخفض تاثير التضخم وحتى
سياسات الها علاقه
التطور المدني والهجره من الريف الى
المدينه وتوسع المدن
الزراعيه الشاسعه بالفعل دكتور مازن ساعود
اليك انت اشرت الى نقطه مهمه جدا اريد
التحول بها للدكتور فاضل وقد اشار اليها
وهي المتعلقه بان الاسباب كانت ازمه
كورونا صحيح بعدها هذه الحرب الدائره في
اوكرانيا والازمه معها بينها وبين روسيا
لكن اين المسؤوليه المحليه في ذلك اشرت
الى دول الخليج بانها تملك الموارد
وبالتالي هي بعيده عن ذلك لكن ربما هذه
النظره النمطيه لدول الخليج لان هناك ما
يتحدث بان لديها خطط حقيقيه وهي التي تخلو
من مساحات زراعيه كبيره غير ان انها
الغذائي افضل بكثير من دول عربيه لديها
ملايين الهكتارات لكنها للاسف لا تحقق هذا
الامن الغذائي اذا اين الخلل اليس ربما في
الخطط التي تحدث عنها الدكتور مازن في
التخطيط في ربما اعطاء الاهميه اللازمه
لهذا الموضوع محليا ناهيك عن الازمات
الخارجيه
نعم يعني اذا ما اردنا التحدث عن الخلل
فالخلل يكمن اولا بان جميع ينادي
بزياده الاستثمارات في الزراعه ولكن لا
يوجد في العديد من هذه الدول قانون بيئه
استثماريه
يشجع المستثمر والقطاع الخاص على الولوج
في هذا المجال وايضا يحفز صغار المزارعين
اللي هم 85% من مزارعيننا
ويشجعهم للاستمرار وهذه وهذا نفس القانون
والبيئه الاستثماريه تجعل الوصول الى
التكنولوجيا والتكنولوجيا مكلفه الان احنا
في تحدي عنا في الانتاجيه وفي تحدي عنا في
التغير المناخي لا يمكن مجابهتها الا
بالتكنولوجيا الحديثه خليني اعطي مثل بسيط
على ما يتم الان عمله في الوطن العربي اذا
نظرنا الى بعض دول الخليج وعلى سبيل
المثال والسعوديه هنالك دخلت في مشاريع
زراعيه كبرى ادخلت فيها التكنولوجيات وسوف
تسهم في انتاج زراعي راح يساهم في زياده
نسبه الاكتفاء الذاتي لن تصل الى اكتفاء
الذاتي لكن راح يساهم وهذا في الاتجاه
الصحيح نرى على الجانب الاخر بعض الدول
بدات بالاهتمام بهم اخر وهو التنميه
الريفيه لان بدي تعالج مشكله قدره على
الوصول للغذاء والفقر في المناطق الريفيه
فدوله مثل مصر والمغرب بدات بهذا الموضوع
نجد الجزائر على سبيل المثال في جنوب شرق
الجزائر المساحات الواسعه من الاراضي بدا
الاهتمام بزراعتها بالقمح وزياده
الانتاجيه عنده مشكله في الانتاجيه ففي
محاولات انا لا انكر ان هنالك محاولات لكن
هل ترقى هذه المحاولات الى مستوى التحدي
هل هل سوف تقوم هذه بحل كل الموضوع ام
نبحث عن جزيئات فقط فلذلك لابد ان نرجع
الى اولا تحفيز البيئه الاستثماريه
وتمكينها ثانيا حل المواضيع المستعصيه
سابقا مثل حيازه الاراضي اللي معظمها اما
لكبار المالكين او للدوله وهذه مشكله
كبيره جدا تواجه اي مستثمر في القطاع
الزراعي ومن ثم نبدا الى ادخال
التكنولوجيات انا ما بدي اطيل عليك بس
ادخال التكنولوجيه عنصر مهم جدا قد يعمل
لدينا الفرق هذه نقطه مهمه قد تعمل الفرق
وتسد العجز في بعض الدول لكن دعني اتحول
بنقطه مهمه ايضا ارسلت الي وتابعناها في
فيلم الليله شهادات بعض المستثمرين في
المجال في المجال الزراعي والفلاحين صغار
الفلاحين الذين يتشبثون في الارض رغم كل
الصعوبات ونتساءل حقيقه لماذا تغيب خطط
حقيقيه وسؤال للدكتور
لماذا تغيب فعلا خطط حقيقيه لدعم هؤلاء
لكي يبقوا في ارضهم لكي ربما يستطيعوا ان
يصمدوا امام كل هذه المشاكل التي تحيط بهم
يعني هناك بعض الدول تتوفر على مقدرات
الانتاج الزراعي لكن الحكومه تفضل
الاستيراد على تشجيع الانتاج المحلي كيف
يمكن ان يفهم ذلك هل مثل هذه الامور
تحركها ايضا ربما دوافع سياسيه
شوفي الحقيقه لكي نكون عادلين بمقاربتنا
للامور
حتى العام
2008 يعني الازمه الماليه العالميه التي
حدثت في العام 2007 حتى ذلك الحين كان
هناك نوع من الاتفاق العالمي او هيك من
على ما يسمى نظريه الميزات التفاضليه في
حركه التجاره العالميه يعني كل بلد يتخصص
بما هو يملك فيه ميزه تفاضليه فاذا انت
تملك ميزه تفاضليه في صناعه النسيج على
سبيل المثال تخصص فقط في ذلك وانت تستطيع
من خلال بيع نسيجك ان تستورد ما تحتاج من
منتجات اخرى كمواد غذائيه اذا انت تتخصص
في التكنولوجيا او ميزتك التفاضليه هي في
التكنولوجيا فتخصص بالتكنولوجيا بدات هذه
النظريه العالميه بنظريه الميزه التفاضليه
في التجاره العالميه تهتز مع الازمه
الماليه في العام 2007 2008 وتداعياتها
التي ادت الى اهتزاز النظام الليبرالي
العالمي واهتزاز ما يسمى بالواشنطن الذي
قام عليه الاقتصاد المالي العالمي منذ
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه وما وصلنا
اليه مؤخرا من صعود الاحزاب القوميه بما
فيها في الولايات المتحده مع وصول الرئيس
ترامب الى الى الى رئاسه الجمهوريه رئيس
جمهوريه امريكي ينادي بخروج امريكا من
منظمه التجاره العالميه تخيلي يعني البلد
الذي نظر على مدى عشرات السنين بموضوع
حريه التجاره والميزات التفاضليه يصل رئيس
يريد ان يقطع التجاره مع العالم وان يركز
على ما يسمى الامن الغذائي والامن القومي
ثم اتت جائحه كورونا التي كانت كما يقول
القشه التي كاظم الدار كانت يعني هي
المسمار الاخير في نعش
ما يسمى هذه النظريه وجعلت الكثير من
البلدان تتجه بالفعل الى موضوع الامن
الغذائي
وتقاربه على اساس سيادي لانه صار واضح انه
الميزات نظريه الميزه التفاضليه هي
نظريه غير قادره على ان تتعاطى مع الصدمات
التي قد يتعرض لها العالم وهي غير قاضله
على انتاج
شو بيقولوا على انتاج فرص العمل فرص العمل
التي يحتاجها هذه البلدان
لكي توفر الرفاهيه لشعوبها لنتذكر انه بلد
كالولايات المتحده يعني هكذا نتكلم عن
العالم العربي كالولايات المتحده الرئيس
ترامب في حملته الانتخابيه ذهب الى هذه
المصانع التي اقفلت وقال لهم التجاره مع
الصين هي التي اقفلتكم
واراد ان يقطع هذه العلاقات التجاريه اذا
كان هناك يعني اهت عالمي او
بنظريات مختلفه عن التي يهتم بها العالم
اليوم ونحن اذا امام فرصه تاريخيه كعرب
لان ننظر الى هذا كتحد اساسي يجب ان
نتعاطى معه وبالاخص سيدتي وبالاخر وهذا
تحدي له ادواته العلميه والتكنولوجيه كما
اشار الدكتور فاضل واعود اليها التي يمكن
ان تقلب الموازين بالفعل وبالتالي سؤالنا
هنا الليله ما مدى كفايه وكفاءه ايضا
الانفاق على هذه الابحاث سواء الزراعيه او
حتى السمكيه الحيوانيه التي يمكن كلها
بالفعل ان تسهم في تحقيق هذا الامن
الغذائي للدول في عالمنا العربي هل نولي
وتولي الدول بالفعل الاهتمام الكافي لهذا
الموضوع ما معلوماتكم بهذا الخصوص
انا شخصيا معلوماتي بان معظم هذه الدول
التي يجب ان تقوم بدورها كممكن
في عمليه الانتاج الزراعي ليست مستثمره
ماذا نعني بممكن مممكن يؤمن الابحاث
اللازمه لزياده الانتاجيه
وتعزيز القيمه التفاضليه
اللي موجوده في كل دوله ممكن لان يجعل
الوصول الى التمويل بالنسبه للمستثمر
وصغار المزارعين ممكنا حتى يستطيع من
ادخال التكنولوجيات ممكن بالوصول الى
الاسواق وجلب القيمه الاعلى ممكن
بالزراعات او الصناعات التابعه واللاحقه
للزراعه لزياده القيمه اذا تحولت الحكومات
الى دورها كممكن في عمليه الانتاج سوف تجد
القطاع الخاص يقوم بالاستثمارات
بشكل وبشكل كبير جدا ومربح ويزيد من نسبه
الاكتفاء الذاتي لدينا انا في كثير من
الامثله اللي ممكن اذكرها واللي بتبين انه
احنا قصرنا المسؤولين لدينا في القطاع كان
لديهم تقصير في هذا المجال طبعا التقصير
لم يكن بشكل شخصي وانما كان الجو العام
لنظم الحكم تعطي اهميه قليله لهذا الموضوع
لذلك برجع بحكي احنا حتى نستطيع ان نصل
بمرحله من لا اقول للاكتفاء الذاتي ولا
الامان التام وانما على الاقل بنسبه كبيره
منها
تمكننا من ان يكون لدى مجتمعنا مرونه في
الاستجابه للصدمات والكوارث سواء كانت
الطبيعيه وشفنا الزلزال في شمال سوريا او
كانت من صنع الانسان حاسب النزاع الموجود
في اليمن وفي سوريا وفي الصومال او الهزات
الاقتصاديه الدوليه
ايضا التي اكتشف العالم بان هذه المنطقه
الجغرافيه الصغيره يعني كانت تعتبر سله ان
صح التعبير للعالم اجمع في العديد من
الامور الحبوب والزيوت تحديدا ومن هنا
السؤال اراضينا في المنطقه العربيه
الشاسعه السودان مثلا يعتبر سله العالم
العربي لكن لا يتم الاستغلال بالشكل
الصحيح بعد الارقام فقط انتاجيه 31% من
الاراضي الزراعيه العربيه هي اما في
انخفاض او انخفاض المتوسط او تتعرض حتى
لضغوط فقط 6% من الاراضي تتميز بارتفاع
انتاجيتها يعني لماذا ربما يعجز العالم
العربي عن استغلال كامل هذه المساحات من
الاراضي الشاسعه والمقدره بمئتين وعشرين
مليون هكتار ولماذا اوكرانيا الصغيره
جغرافيا يعني استطاعت واكتشف العالم بانها
تستطيع بالف عل ان تستغل هذه الاراضي
وتكون سله مهمه للعالم اجمع
يعني اذا اذا السؤال الي شيء
نعم اول شيء انا بدي ارجع لاوكرانيا
اوكرانيا هي لا تطعم العالم اوكرانيا
خليني اذكر بانه الانتاج على سبيل المثال
القمح القمح هنالك انتاج سنوي 800 مليون
يستهلك العالم
سنويا والباقي تخزين ونسبه التخزين ما
يقارب الثلاثين الى التخزين الاحتياطي ما
يقارب الثلاثين او 29% ما يدخل في سوق
التجاره العالميه هو فقط 195 مليون طن ما
تقوم اوكرانيا بتزويده من القمح هو ما
يقارب 16 مليون طن فهو رقم ادى الى خلخله
سعر الغذاء في العالم ولكن دوله من مثل
الصين هي رقم واحد في انتاج القمح في
العالم دوله مثل اليابان تنتج 108 مليون
طن اقد اوكرانيا ست مرات والصين كذلك لذلك
نحن لما نيجي
لحالنا لوضع قريتنا وبلدنا السودان على
سبيل المثال ذكر تقريرك ماذا في احد
مشاريع التنميه خربت المضخات اخذت خمس
سنوات حتى يبدلوها البنيه التحتيه او دور
الوزاره دور الحكومه بان تكون الممكن
للانتاج الزراعي لا تقوم به ماذا سوف يفعل
هذا المستثمر راح استثماره وبالتالي اصبح
هذا الاستثمار غير مضمون واصبح في مهب
الريح من سوف يجرؤ على القيام بالاستثمار
مره اخرى نحن من نعيق هذا الموضوع عن طريق
فهمنا الخاطئ لدور الحكومه الحكومه هي
ممكن في هذا القطاع هاي نقطه خليني اذكر
نقطه مهمه اخرى لم ينتبه العرب الا مؤخرا
لها
مش بالضروره انا اذهب الى العمل
العربي والتكامل العربي الزراعي المشترك
مثل ما ذكر اخونا وحبيبنا مدير عام
المنظمه العربيه للتنميه الزراعيه مش
بالضروره هذا هذا حلم 40 سنه واحنا بنشتغل
عليه وشفنا كل شركات
العمل العربي النابعه من جامعه الدول
العربيه لم تؤدي الغرض المطلوب منها لذلك
يجب ان نذهب الى الكلاسترز المجموعات
الصغيره الدول المتقاربه
تجمعات شبه اقليميه مش مفترض انها كمان
متقاربه جغرافيا ممكن تكون افتراضيا يعني
لما نيجي الى حوض ان شاء الله الامور
الامنيه بتكون كويسه بين سوريا والعراق
المساحه اللي بين دجله والفرات هذه مزاعه
تنتج قمح بظرف سابق ما يقارب الثمانيه
ونصف مليون طن ممكن ان تنتج مع
التكنولوجيات الحديثه ما يصل الى العشرين
المناطق اللي في في الجزائر وتونس
ومصر والسودان والبحيره المشكله خلف السد
العالي هذه مناطق اذا ما تم تهيئه البيئه
الاستثماريه المناسبه انا متاكد هنالك
قطاع خاص قادر انه يقوم بالاستثمار وجلب
التكنولوجيا الزراعي وتحقيق جزء من الامن
الغذائي ما الذي يمنع ربما مجهود جماعي في
هذا الاطار يعني في بدايه الثمانينات من
القرن الماضي المنظمه العربيه التنميه
الزراعيه تقدمت بمشروع ضخم للامن الغذائي
العربي يغطي 20 عاما من سنه 1980 لغايه
2000 يشمل 153 مشروعا
ود للمشاهد كلمه ان يسمع جيدا صفر مشروع
من هذه المشاريع تم انجازه لماذا اين
الخلل
سيدتي هناك يعني هناك بعض
الشوائب والتحديات التي لا يتحمل
مسؤوليتها كموضوع المياه مثلا يعني لا
دعونا لا ننسى ان العالم العربي يغطي 11%
من اليابسه هو يعني نسبته الى نسبه
اليابسه في العالم هي 11% بينما نسبه
حصوله على الامطار على اليابسه في العالم
هي 2% فقط ونسبه الانهر التي يجري تجري في
على يابسته 0.7% فقط يعني موضوع ندره
المياه وصعوبه الحصول عليها هو تحدي اساسي
ليس في ايدينا ولكن هناك ايضا امور اخرى
في ايدينا كموضوع استصلاح الاراضي
والاستثمار في البحوث العلميه والزراعيه
تمكين دور الدول او الحكومات لتمكين كما
قال الزميل للتمويل ولدعم بعض يعني بعض
المراحل من عمليه الانتاج والتوزيع تخزين
وايضا الاستثمار بالتكنولوجيا على جميع
الاصعده الزراعه التحصيل
التوزيع التخزين ومن ثم حتى يعني
التبريد كل هذه هي تحديات في ايدينا ويجب
العمل على ان نواجهها لاننا سيدتي اريد ان
اطرح عليك رقما مخيفا يعني نحن اليوم في
العام 2020 كان عدد سكان العالم العربي
390 مليون نسمه وهو متوقع ان يكون في
العام 2050
655 مليون نسمه عندما كنا عشرين
390 مليون نسمه نحن
استوردنا 110 مليار دولار من الغذاء اي
50% من استهلاكنا وبالتالي اذا لم ننظر
جديا الى هذا الموضوع سنواجه كارثه في 25
عاما عندما يكون عدد سكاننا ان نعرف لا
قدر الله طبعا لا احد يتمنى هذه الك وارث
لكن لابد من تخطيط حتى لا نصل الى هذه
النقطه ما التداعيات والتاثيرات استمرار
هذه الفجوه الغذائيه في العالم العربي
باعتقادك والثمن الذي يمكن ان يدفع
اقتصاديا نعم لكن سياسيا واجتماعيا ايضا
الحلقه المفرغه التي نعاني منها يعني عدم
القدره على الوصول الى الامن الغذائي
والفقر والبطاله يؤدي الى التطرف ويؤدي
الى ارتفاع
النزاعات
الاضطرابات التي تؤدي الى بدورها الى عدم
القدره على جلب الاستثمار وبالتالي عدم سد
الفجوه في
العجز التجاري والمزيد من العجوزات في
ميزان المدفوعات وبالتالي المزيد من
العجوزات على صعيد الموازنات العامه ما
يؤدي الى ضعف السياسات يعني هذه حركه
مفرغه سيدتي اذا لم نكسرها في مكان ما اذا
لم نكسرها ستؤدي الى المزيد من الاضطرابات
التي نشهدها في عالمنا العربي والذي نشهد
يعني من عقد الى اخر المزيد من التفكك
والمزيد من ارتفاع معدلات الفقر بالبطاله
والعنف الذي ياتي معها
احدى ابواب الحلول
برايي قد يكون الاستثمارات البينيه
العربيه لانه اليوم عندما يقول تقريرك انه
32% فقط من الاراضي
الصالحه للزراعه في العالم العربي هي
مزروعه هذا يعني ان هناك 68% من الفرصه
الكامنه قد تكون في بلدان غير قابله على
الاستثمار ولكنها فرصه لبلدان اخرى
المشترك بين هذه الدول ليحمل الاخر
ويستفيد يعني كل واحد من الاخر الذي يملك
المال يعني يستثمر في البلدان التي لا
تملك المال لكن ربما تملك الاراضي الشاسعه
ربما تملك اليد العامله ايضا ومن هنا
اهميه هذا الموضوع سؤال ربما اخير اتحول
به للدكتور فاضل لان الوقت كذا ان ينتهي
هل هناك ادراك دكتور فاضل باعتقادك لاهميه
هذا الموضوع وانعكاساته للاسف شديد التي
يمكن ان تكون على الجانب الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي
والسياسي في الدول العربيه وبالتالي تفطن
لهذا الموضوع ووضع المجهود اللازم فيه
نعم هو هو لغايه الان لم يصل الاحساس بان
هذا الموضوع سوف يكون له اثار اجتماعيه
واقتصاديه وقد تؤثر على السلم المجتمع
وتؤثر يعني نحن نعلم بان مختلف الشعوب
التي خرجت للشارع خرجت من اجل قوت عيشها
صحيح الحريه والكرامه والعداله الاجتماعيه
لكن على راسها ايضا الحياه الكريمه
نعم هذا انا اقصد لم يصل الى صاحب القرار
بحيث انه ياخذ هذا على محمل الجد
كلما تم كان ضمن اطار براي المسؤولين
المحدد لم
ينقل هذه الفكره ولذلك هذا ما نراه حتى في
ردود الافعال يعني عندما نسمع الان هنالك
اجتماعات وزاريه لاربع دول وزراء الزراعه
في اربع دول للحديث عن الامن الغذائي كل
ما حصل في هذه الاجتماعات لمده يومين وصار
لهم اجتمعوا سنتين هو فقط تسهيل مرور
اجراءات
تسهيل الاجراءات ومرور البضائع بين هذه
الدول وهذا لم يرتقي الى مستوى مهم جدا
اللي هو مستوى كيف نعمل اقليميا او شبه
اقليميا حتى نستطيع ان نحقق الامن الغذائي
وكذلك هنالك عده دول المفاوضات حتى على
مستوى رؤسائها ثلاثه دول ت في هذا الموضوع
منذ سنتين لم ينتقل اي شيء الى الارض
خليني انا اذكر نقطه بجوز فاتتني في
البدايه احنا في عنا موضوع مهم جدا جدا
غافلين عنه وهذا تحدي كبير وهذا من واجب
الحكومات المعلومات
المعلومات لا يوجد شبكه لمعلومات الامن
الغذائي
لكن للاسف وقتنا انتهى تماما اشكر في
الختام ضيفي الكريمين معنى كان معنا من
عمان ضد الفاضل الزعبي خليل الامن الغذائي
المركزي جنب للدراسات والممثل السابق
لمنظمه الفاو في منطقه الشرق الاوسط كما
اشكر ضيفي الكريم من بيروت الدكتور مازن
السويد رئيس مؤسسه الاستثمارات في لبنان
خبروا الاقتصاد الدولي
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]